the quest for the perfect playlist now
includes Spotify iTunes radio beats are
do I Heart Radio google music amazon
music title now how do you think about
who's my competition and Who am I so
anybody that has a radio product
broadcast radio is obviously the largest
competitor iTunes radio when it came out
definitely direct competitor and so we
think about sort of our own future it's
really about how do we how do we remain
the best playlist building business
around and I think so far the numbers
bear it out you let me keep growing in
spite of all this competition so sirius
XM is that a competitor absolutely yeah
Apple buying beats is that something
that you think about yeah of course what
I always think with Apple goes is never
underestimate never never think you know
what they're doing it's a very smart
company so beats music will be retooled
and relaunched this summer presumably
maybe a new name how worried are you
about that well we haven't we actually
haven't lacked for competition for a
long time and and what I've learned I
keep learning this year year after year
is building a great play this is
fantastically hard to do and so we've we
find over time more and more confidence
in the differentiation we have you know
did you ever meet Steve Jobs yeah I did
did you talk to him about the future of
music I know I always said two words to
each other we had the great honor of
being on stage in cupertino when they
announced multitasking on the iPhone and
they wanted Pandora highlighted so
myself and are then CTO tom conway I've
got to give a three or four minute
presentation tom and i spent a week in a
room rehearsing a three minute
presentation and we were kept under lock
and key and escorted in and out of the
building and we had to rehearse the talk
many many times for a successively
smaller and smaller group of executives
until the final thumbs up and then he
did say good job after our presentation
so i take that as great praise there's
been always kind of simmering talk about
apple and pandora why doesn't Apple by
Pandora maybe Apple tried to five
Pandora's any of that true well we don't
comment on stuff like that of course but
you know I look at them as this an
incredible partner it makes sense
they've had radio products and things
that would be
p with us but you know stepping back
they've sort of invented this field that
we benefit from Spotify just raised four
hundred million dollars at a day and a
half billion dollar valuation that's
more than twice Pandora's market cap
they're more focused on subscriptions
Pandora's more focused on ads how do you
think about that comparison we stick to
our knitting you know having been in
this business for a long time you know
it's an exciting business as lots of
drama and interesting news and I've
always found the best thing we can do is
just stay focused on what we do we have
figured out how to monetize internet
radio which no one else has we've also
built a huge national sales force so we
have hundreds of sellers you know 50
markets around the country who are now
penetrated into local advertising and in
the long run that kind of foundation is
how you build a really big business over
the years